Halloween being a week before this
country votes for president in the years
that I can recollect usually the most
popular Halloween mask the political
mask Tory's a good indication of who's
gonna win the election
we pretty much did them for every
presidential election Richard Nixon was
a very good seller Reagan Reagan was the
best-selling mask when he was running
for president the Clinton mess
definitely were the best-selling mass
the Bush mass was a very good indicator
the Obama mass also sold a lot better
and he won the election
Trump is selling a lot more than a
Clinton heir to taught me several times
the quantity of Trump however this year
might be slightly different for a couple
of reasons one of our political
candidates Ismail one of our political
candidates is female please understand
that when you talking about wearing a
latex or a vinyl mask most women will
not put a heavy sweaty latex mask on men
wear most of the mass
the other thing is that one of our
candidates is so controversial that
maybe that they're buying that mask as a
mockery quite frankly this is the first
time that I can tell you that the
candidate mass that is out selling I'm
not so sure is an accurate indication of
who's going to win the election